[Music]
perhaps the best news of the day came
not from any of the games but from alex
smith his wife elizabeth posted on
social media that alex is home out of
the hospital after four weeks surgery
complications infections but alex smith
home for the holidays and doing well
that is a relief because
a couple of weeks ago
when the news starts to come out about
the infection and removal of the
hardware and external fixators and just
it's it can be very very serious so it's
great news to see that he's doing well
great news it really is alex smith's a
great guy uh and that's a tough injury
that was gruesome and i i played with
joe jaravicius who had a deal with the
staph infection and a surgically
repaired knee that ruined his career so
uh this is a real thing that goes on in
the nfl from time to time and uh best to
alex smith all right it's superlatives
time for week 15 chris sims i'll let you
have the honors what do you got well
it's hard for you know i guess the first
one i i gotta go with uh you know one of
my old favorites and you know i'm gonna
build a wall so big
chris ballard's gonna build a wall so
big
he's not even gonna pay for it
he's going to make him
pay for it and that's the indianapolis
colts offense just how phenomenal that
was yesterday i mean they really are
they're like the great wall of
indianapolis right now i'm having fun of
course yes uh just because i think
they're amazing they really are i mean
the three first rounders they have on
their offensive line but what they did
to that dallas cowboy defense mike i
think we got to talk about it a little
just not only dominating the line of
scrimmage in the run game i mean you
look at the highlights the ones that
matter in that game it's really marlon
mack right up the middle of that dallas
defense right and then you know added to
that we've seen this dallas defensive
line ruined games for teams the last few
weeks you know how many sacks this great
defensive line had yesterday against the
great wall of indianapolis zero that's
how good this group is they are capable
of really matching up against the best
d-lines in football and just saying so
what bring it we can play a man man man
to man mano imano i was going to say
there but either way the colts frank
reich andrew luck uh that offense and
that offensive line is really what's
changed that team around i talked to
marlon mack after the game and you know
we we have discussed in recent weeks
that with the cowboys you get a feel
early on whether or not their formula is
going to work because it's very simple
marlon mack said from the first drive
yeah he knew that it was going to work
that they were going to have a big day
right and it helped having matt eberflus
as the defensive coordinator the cults
he had been with the cowboys for seven
years he knows their defense he knows
their offense they're able to shut down
that offense they know the personnel
they know what they like to do right and
defensively they run the same defense
they know how to attack it so it worked
out very well for the colts who get to
eight and six and they are very much
alive for the postseason now the cowboys
have to they have to be a little nervous
because they only have a one game lead
over both washington and philadelphia
going into the final two weeks of the
season they got to get that vibe back
and that's one of the things we've seen
when you're in that mode where you're
winning winning winning once you slide
off the horse yeah it's hard to get back
on sometimes now the buccaneers coming
to town next week they should be able to
beat them but
but uh who knows all right for me who
knows for me the uh the this is the why
didn't they fire that guy a long time
ago award and really when you think
about mike zimmer the vikings head coach
having to come out publicly multiple
times and say we want to run the ball we
need to run the ball it makes you wonder
how many times privately he had made
that point to former offensive
coordinator john d filippo that's one of
the things tony dungey who was an
assistant in minnesota years ago has
pointed out why did it have to get to
this point right for the vikings to
actually run the football and they
finally did now with kevin stefanski as
the offensive coordinator and the
offense was balanced the offense was
effective i talked to stefan diggs after
the game and i thought he would be
very because he's you know very engaging
and very candid and i thought he'd talk
about how this was a wake-up call and
you know nobody's safe now and if we're
not going to do things the way coach
zimmer wants there's going to be
accountability he just kind of shrugged
and he said look this is what we can do
this this is this is on the players and
we know what we can do and we did it he
said that the offensive line got the
game balls yesterday the offensive line
hadn't been playing like a unit worthy
of game balls pretty much all year long
but they opened up the running lanes for
dalvin cook who had a career day
latavius murray gets plenty of reps in
the running game that set up play action
passing that was how stefan diggs scored
his touchdown great throw by kirk
cousins to aldrick robinson late he's
kirk when he makes a good throw he's
kurt when he makes a bad throw kirk was
around more than kurt yesterday although
there were a couple of kurt sightings
yeah that game was 21-00 and it becomes
21-7 like that because of the pick six
on a receiver screen there yeah and even
though the final score was 41-17 we
forget yeah that there was a time there
yeah in the third quarter where it's
like oh boy
yeah right no no doubt about it but it
just you know again it shows when you
know your coaching staff and your team
is determined to do something and they
were determined to run the ball that
week and have more plays in the game
plan you know it's the way minnesota
should be playing they got a great
defense
play through that defense run the ball
and then you're going to get your
one-on-one opportunities with those two
receivers on the outside and that's when
they can make the pass game go so good
for the vikings maybe they got it going
i'm going to stay
kind of with the um
the kicking it old school award i'm
calling it just because of all the
hundred yard rushers we saw yesterday uh
i didn't want to steal your dalvin cook
thunder so i let you have that one
because i didn't i thought if i went
first i knew you wanted that one yes but
i do want to know you prefer to make me
nervous going on about building a wall
and making somebody else pay for it but
i do like making you score them on that
but 10 100 yard rushers in the nfl
yesterday and only three or two 300 yard
passers girl i mean we had golf last
night who had to throw the ball
times to get to 300 yards and we had
philip rivers on thursday night but i
think what we are we're seeing or what
we're seeing this time of the year in
the nfl uh with the elements the
pendulum is swinging the pendulum is
swinging you better watch out but the
run game of course is just such a vital
part for match-ups on a weekly basis
helping out your defense and i think you
know over the last few weeks we've seen
some more old school down downhill smash
mouth type
running and offense from teams all over
the league and yesterday you know
whether it was gus edwards in baltimore
and nick chubb on saturday night you
know we talked about marlon mack and the
colts you know henry had a great job a
great day with the titans you got
television kevin coleman who killed it
for the falcons
pittsburgh steelers jalen samuels so uh
42 yards 19 carries first time ever had
19 carries at any level of football in
his life
it's amazing and i watched him play at
nc state last year he's got a you're all
over him great skill skill uh set there
but no no not not you didn't hit the
same home run you hit last year without
america all right but still i said watch
out for him all year yeah but uh it's
just refreshing to me in the nfl where
we're 300 yards is just a common place
to see this week where it was run game
oriented and not as many 300 yard pass
there's kind of an old school weekend in
the nfl the weather is turning and the
stakes are rising and single elimination
football is coming and this is going to
be a great test and we've seen this
building the high-powered pinball
offenses against the old school smash
mouth football and i have a feeling this
year when it's all said and done it's
going to be one of those teams old
school plays old school football it's
going to win or somebody who's got
balance between right offense defense
and run game pass game yeah and and it's
somebody's gonna catch fire at the right
time and they're gonna find a way to win
games and i think it makes for a very
exciting 11-game postseason tournament
which is only
what 19 days away it gets started in 19
days amazing all right uh here's my next
one and and this is an honor of you
chris this is the self scouting of
himself award thank you you mentioned
derek henry i talked to him yesterday
after the game and i looked at his
performance early in the year in his
performance more recently and and i said
to him what what happened right why do
we have this sudden
resurgence and it really isn't all that
sudden what happened was week eight they
had a buy so they had seven games on the
front end seven games on the back end he
went and he looked at his film
and he realized he's
he's trying too hard right he's
trying to hit a home run on every play
so he's giving up too quickly on plays
where it's not easy he's going down too
easily he's running out of bounds so
he's he's thinking that i can't get
anything out of this instead of fighting
for an extra yard or two you know he he
wants 50 he wants 60 he was giving up
too quickly and now what he's doing is
he's grinding he's grinding his grinding
and he's using that size right and i
think the fact that he wasn't used
excessively early in the year he's got
that that that pool of
of extra yeah i don't know he can take
more bodies he can take more carries
he's fresher than other guys so
in the first seven games of the season
he was averaging 39 yards per game yeah
in the last seven games he's averaging
87 yards per game and he's yards per
carry 3.25 before he did the self
scouting of himself
6.69 in seven games since then this
isn't just a two-game phenomenon this
guy has gotten better we just didn't
really notice it until he had that
explosion on thursday night last week
against the jaguars but 408 yards the
last two weeks six touchdowns and if he
can keep it up this is one of those
teams that can swipe one of those spots
in the afc field and can be a factor
when we get to january well they can be
scary you're right about that because of
dean pease and frable on the defensive
side they're a game plan type defense
who can do creative things out of
nowhere
and then you know it is i mean it's
interesting with derek henry you know
it's it's always odd to see a tailback
that size in the nfl and i do i think i
mean of course i agree with this
assessment uh
he does have moments where you go man
come on run smash it in there a little
harder run in there a little harder and
i do think because of his size and his
length you know it's hard for those tall
running backs at times because they're
worried about their legs getting chopped
out all the time and they're worried
about losing a knee and there's just so
much surface area for defensive players
to hit but uh it's good to see him make
that turn around and self-evaluate
itself because that will always make you
a better football player anything else
uh i mean i kind of wanted to give like
the bludgeoning award to uh the
baltimore ravens i'm feeling like i want
to give the run game love today and
again the baltimore ravens are showing
like
you don't need to throw it for 300 yards
on a weekly basis to win football games
or 100 or 100 exactly right i mean they
barely got over 100 yesterday and lamar
jackson had a few good throws in the
game he had a few errant throws where he
struggled throwing the ball in the
reigns certainly but
so what they didn't care i mean the
baltimore ravens i mean it's it's
amazing to watch how many different ways
and styles they can run the ball whether
it's speed sweeps or lamar off the edge
or gus edwards down the middle uh they
just got it all and they've really
created this offense and i got to give
greg roman a lot of credit along with
marty morningweg because greg roman came
from san francisco he was coaching colin
kaepernick that he has really added to
the inventory of this offense and they
have become a really in-depth running
schematical team to where you know
they're just as annoying to deal with
and game plan for as you know a team
that throws the ball 40 times a game and
has all these different formations
because you have to worry about so many
different things and what they do in the
run game and different people along with
it uh that is it's pretty fascinating
we're seeing like i feel like it's like
a a wishbone team in the nfl which is
very rare remember they were one of the
only teams that flirted seriously with
simon kaepernick in 2017 remember that
they were going to bring him in and and
something happened there was something
that that kaepernick's girlfriend said
supposedly that caused the ravens to
sour it was kind of a lame explanation
at the end of the day but maybe this has
been
a matter of them finding the quarterback
to make this go
and now you have to wonder all right joe
flacco undoubtedly going to be out
unless lamar jackson gets injured and
flacco comes in and sparks some sort of
a super bowl run but next year do they
go rg3 is the backup do they think about
kaepernick i mean you know next year's a
long way away but it's not that far away
and if lamar jackson's the guy
and we hear all the time you want to
have supposedly yeah you want to have a
guy who's the backup who runs the same
offense you want to find one or two guys
behind lamar jackson who can come in and
do the same thing yeah i would think
that rg3 would make sense to be the
backup for them and what they want to do
because it is a similar skill set and
you don't want joe flacco there in the
background to con constantly not making
18.5 million exactly right so that's not
gonna happen but man the ravens they've
rushed for 200 yards four times this
year 242 yards yesterday and again it
goes back to our playoff conversation
and you might have to play some outside
ugly games in the elements and baltimore
ravens are one of those teams between
their defense and their run game that
will not be affected no matter if it's a
monsoon or a cold day whatever it is
they're going to be fine
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports